[Musique]
elle a dû marcher de maurepas connaît
une nouvelle étape à trailer 110
dévastateur de 2019 le site est au coeur
d'une concertation les mort patients ont
découvert le week-end dernier les plans
imaginés pour une reconstruction en 2024
un couple il est noir que nous juste
parmi les nations aurélien et julianne
moore un habitant de lui mais ont
accueilli pendant deux ans le jeune
henry dauman une cérémonie s'est tenue à
levallois perret les six agents du
service sont actuellement aux formations
la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux va bientôt être
armés le nouveau maire de
mantes-la-jolie devrait être connu au
plus tard le 22 mai les dates pour la
municipale partielle sont connus premier
tour le 15 mai quatre candidats se sont
déclarés dont raphaël cogner maire
démissionnaire en janvier la maison de
l'europe des yvelines a 20 ans et pour
cette double décennie la structure
organisée un temps des changes pensé et
créé l'agriculture de demain ce 16
février c'était le coup d'envoi pour les
startups sélectionnées par hectare le
plus grand campus agricoles du monde aux
entreprises ont aussi développé une
yvelinoise décor et gabriela boda
directrice musicale de la maîtrise de
trappes a reçu les insignes de chevalier
de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur
[Musique]